the album is called mccartney three i
think he called it mccartney three
because
when you go and you record every
instrument
that's why you're calling it mccartney
three am i correct on that yeah
i did make only one mccartney two and
this is mccartney three
i mean i was sitting around with these
tracks thinking what am i gonna do with
this
and then a little light bulb went off i
thought you've played all the
instruments this is mccartney three
i seriously didn't know i was making an
album
so there's a whole different feel
that one of the tracks on the album
you'll hear is called deep deep feeling
it's like eight minutes long and i'm
listening to it
this is just for my phone so yeah it can
be eight minutes great
more to listen to when i get home you
know but when it starts to sort of
get near to this is going to be an album
i started thinking well
i should probably edit it down so i said
well listen let me just play it for me
one more time
so i got the headphones on and i thought
no i'm not chopping this
this works is this a nice point in your
life to be releasing an album i mean the
pressure is not the same
you know it's not like you have anything
to prove yeah it is it is a nice point
yeah
because you know i'm happily married to
nancy
and you know we have a great time
together how is nancy
she's lovely does she say to you paul
where are the songs about me did you
write songs about nancy specifically on
this album i hope
i said they're all about your love is
that what you do
he's a smart man